[Music]
on this Thursday night defending Paul
bernardo's prison transfer the
Correctional Services review went to the
controversial move his safety was at
risk why the decision won't be
overturned the bottleneck from BC's
on-again off-again Port strike the
consequences for consumers too hot to
handle exposure to excessive heat has
wide-ranging impacts for health what's
known as the wet bulb temperature why
it's dangerous and where it's happening
and battle off the turf how Women's
World Cup players still haven't scored
pay Equity despite a raise
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser good
evening to you thanks for joining us
tonight the results of a review Into the
contentious decision to quietly move
notorious serial killer and rapist Paul
Bernardo from a maximum security
facility in Kingston Ontario to a Quebec
medium security prison it's a move that
ignited a political Firestorm the
85-page document all came down to this
line
decisions to reclassify in San Bernardo
to La makaza were sound and followed all
applicable laws and policies
but as David Akin reports it's a
decision bitterly opposed by bernardo's
victims
Paul Bernardo has committed horrific and
unspeakable crimes but despite that and
even though he is a designated dangerous
offender Paul Bernardo will remain at a
medium security prison in La makaza
Quebec the decisions to reclassify this
inmate to medium security and transfer
him to La makaza institution or sound
and followed all applicable laws and
policies this 85-page report details how
Bernardo specifically asked for lamakaza
prison it's a facility which specializes
in housing high-profile sexual offenders
like Bernardo lamakaza institution has
similar perimeter control as a maximum
security institution including high
fences and arm Patrols
moreover protecting Bernardo from other
inmates at his former maximum security
president Kingston Ontario had become a
challenge he required a high degree of
supervision and control because
his safety was at risk the families of
two of his victims Christian French and
lesla Mahaffey strongly opposed the
transfer in a letter their lawyer said
well principles of Rehabilitation are
critical and apply to 99 of the federal
prison population they do not to the
remaining one percent like Paul Bernardo
who are Beyond Rehabilitation that
lawyer Timothy Danson noted that
multiple parole board hearings as
recently as 2021 found Bernardo to have
deviant sexual interests a narcissistic
personality disorder and other traits
that led psychiatrists to label Bernardo
a psychopath Correctional Services
Canada commissioner Ann Kelly did not
disagree despite the fact that
he is at a medium security Institution
does not negate the fact that he is a
psychopath and Kelly says new processes
are in place to better deal with victims
families in these types of situations I
regret any pain and concern this
transfer has caused there is no appeal
of this decision neither the minister of
Public Safety nor a judge can overturn
it as for Bernardo he is up for parole
yet again in four months Farah
David Akin in Ottawa thank you David
Toronto City councilors have voted to
declare gender-based violence and
intimate partner violence and epidemic
in the city now Advocates applaud the
move but they do say that more needs to
be done
I believe every woman should have a
chance
to be free of violence from intimate
partners
and I know the people around me are
working very hard to make that a reality
Chao has spoken candidly about the abuse
her mother experienced from her father
Toronto joins 30 other municipalities
across Ontario that have declared
gender-based violence and epidemic
the on-again off-again strike Saga at
British Columbia ports appears to be
over at least for the time being some 7
400 workers returned to work today after
their Union withdrew its 72-hour strike
notice last night but as tariya Israel
reports the push is now on for all sides
to finally get a deal done and avoid
another work stoppage that could cost
Canadians even more
wow
cargo is moving again at Canada's
busiest port at least for now
workers are chipping away at the massive
backlog in an on-again off-again strike
tying up 800 million dollars a day in
trade the district could not continue
the union rejected a tentative deal with
the employer and then held a one-day
walkout it threatened to escalate the
job action over the weekend
prime minister Justin Trudeau called an
emergency meeting Wednesday with cabinet
ministers that same day the union
reversed course and called off the
weekend strike but there is still no
concrete resolution we're glad to see
that the union is reconsidering the good
offer that was on the table and with no
agreement the bottleneck could keep
growing in a three-week labor dispute
over wages and working conditions every
one day takes about a week to clear the
supply chain we're into day 20.
businesses warn Supply chains have not
fully recovered from the pandemic and
Chaos at Canada's main International
Gateway could take months to recover
from that's a lot of containers and uh
it's a cycle Manitoba's pork producers
ship more than 700 million dollars worth
of meat through the West Coast a year
chilled Port can't sit on the port for
are on the dock forever right it it uh
it has to move and it has a short window
to move and and so the the cost if we
get outside of that window is is a
enormous and there are concerns the
costs could also be higher for consumers
the hope is that prices won't go up as a
result because we're dealing with an
inflation problem at the same time but
you know that's what happened the last
time we ran into supply chain problems
the union declined our request for an
interview while the federal government
would not answer when asked repeatedly
whether it would recall Parliament and
introduce Back To Work legislation if
this labor dispute drags on pharah
churia Israel Ottawa thanks to Ria
it's only the third week in July and
already this is the worst Fire season
ever recorded in Canada
there are around 885 active wildfires
across the country 600 are out of
control and 11 million hectares of land
has burned 10 times the national average
and the wildfires they're more intense
more unpredictable and are causing huge
health concerns as Karen Lieberman
reports they've also turned deadly
Canadians have to be very careful even
more careful than than they are a
reminder and a warning about the dire
situation in this country as Crews from
around the world battle the most
devastating Wildfire season on record
it's very easy for fires to start
whether from from Human cause or natural
causes this one the Donnie Creek
Wildfire burning in northeastern British
Columbia is now larger than Prince
Edward Island it was sparked by a
lightning strike in May with flying
detection plans uh all the time across
the province where we know lightning is
hit to try to catch these fires as
quickly as we can the fires are
destructive and they're deadly near
Peace River Alberta a helicopter pilot
helping fight fires died Wednesday in
what officials are calling an accident
right now there are thousands upon
thousands of people helping out their
neighbors helping out across the country
and we really need to pause and thank
them all and be with the families who've
lost loved ones even as they're trying
to keep rest of us safe to fire Fighters
died in less than a week
nineteen-year-old Devin Gayle in BC and
25 year old Adam yetin in the Northwest
Territories the BC coroner service also
issued a public safety bulletin about
Wildfire smoke after the death of a
young boy with asthma Carter Vai was
nine just the fact that the smoke got so
bad and
and the heat the visibility up here was
just I've never seen it so bad with
Tinder dry conditions wildfires could
grow more intense but climate change may
be the bigger concern moving forward NBC
we are unfortunately becoming accustomed
to forest fires but this year they've
arrived even earlier and they're made
more significant because of widespread
drought conditions we're experiencing
across the province in June the federal
government announced a National Climate
Change adaptation plan with the support
of all provinces and territories the
minister of environment and climate
change said it's a way to ensure Canada
is as prepared as possible able to keep
the impacts of climate change at a
minimum pharah
Karen Lieberman interwano thank you
Karen climate talks in Beijing have
ended without any major new commitments
from China or the United States U.S
climate Envoy John Kerry says more work
is needed to reach agreements on major
climate issues
this is not a one-off meeting
we are already
pinpointing the time for our next
meeting and then even the next one after
that recognizing that we have only about
four months before the cop
there had been a stretch of near radio
silence between the world's two biggest
polluters with tension over Taiwan
canceling previous meetings Kerry says
China did agree that countries should
strive to limit global warming to no
more than 1.5 degrees Celsius and that
the world has to reduce its Reliance on
coal
and in the U.S Southwest right now
record heat is filling up emergency
rooms officials say people are being
treated for second-degree contact burns
from touching pavement that in some
cases has reached 70 degrees Celsius
experts say temperatures are also
staying hotter for longer Jamie moroccer
looks into how much heat is too hot to
handle for humans
it's been so hot in Texas this week
neither water
or shade is providing much relief from
the extreme heat I usually run but in
this heat no some areas in the southern
U.S are treading dangerously close to a
critical wet bulb temperature a
measurement that describes the point at
which water on a thermometer bulb or
sweat from a human stops evaporating
originally thought to be 35 degrees
Recent research suggests 31 degrees
Celsius with 100 percent humidity is the
point our bodies can't physically cool
down
earlier this month nearly all of
Louisiana Mississippi and Arkansas were
under this extreme threat heat that's
getting Global attention exposure to
excessive heat has wide-ranging impacts
for health
often amplifying pre-existing conditions
and resulting in premature death and
disability experts say when exposed to
the elements humans can only survive the
highest wet bulb temperatures for six
hours those extremes you never want to
be at right I mean these are these are
stressful temperatures in many cases
that nighttime signal is even stronger
as an even clearer evidence of global
warming even when it's dark temperatures
aren't coming down as they should
scientists suggest without access to
other cooling methods extreme wet bulb
temperatures could make places like
India and Pakistan uninhabitable in the
U.S it will mean more pressure on our
cities when it's really hot out people
want to use more air conditioning and
that can place stress on the electricity
system we see similar things for water
and other kinds of infrastructure
systems we simply cannot survive without
in this type of heat highlighting how
Reliant we have become and how delicate
our civilization is
Jimmy moroccer Global News Houston
in the heart of South Africa's biggest
city a huge explosion killed at least
one person and injured 48 others during
johannesburg's evening Rush Hour
the blast ripped open roads and flipped
more than 20 cars the explosion was so
strong an area the size of about five
city blocks was damaged now it's still
unclear what caused the explosion but
it's believed in underground gas pipe
ruptured the streets being closed and
the local electricity Supply shut off
over concerns a second explosion could
occur
the warnings of a crisis on the way
coming out the potential ramifications
of Ukraine's collapsed grain export deal
[Music]
for the third straight night emergency
crews in Ukraine worked to douse fires
and tend to be injured as Russian air
attacks targeted the country's Southern
port cities in mikolai of children were
among the nearly 20 people injured after
a three-story residential building was
hit and in Odessa at least two deaths
have been reported following Russian
airstrikes
Russia's attacks are happening at the
same time and the same week it
terminated a wartime deal that allowed
Ukraine to export grain through key
Black Sea ports world leaders are now
warning of a looming Global food crisis
with wheat prices already on the rise
Crystal command Singh looks at what some
say needs to be done to keep the food
supply strong for millions of people
as one of the world's top grain
producers it's pivotal Ukraine's
products get to Market what do we
already know
is that this is going to create a big a
huge food crisis in the world it's a
grim warning from the European Union's
foreign policy Chief the price of wheat
has jumped not only in Europe but the
U.S still experts say it's only about
half of the record price set last year
it's summertime as well it's uh which
means we're in weather markets which
adds a little bit of additional
uncertainty to the markets and so
I don't think anybody really knows what
Putin is going to do next week so that's
part of the volatility race on Monday
Russia pulled out of a deal brokered by
turkey which ensured safe passage of
cargo ships carrying Ukrainian grain
that deal brought down grain prices in
2022 cooling dire warnings like the ones
being conveyed now
save the
clothes
we will have to increase the capacity of
exporting a Ukrainian grain through our
ports which means a bigger effort
would enable Ukraine we have not
speaking from Pakistan a regular
importer of Ukrainian grain the foreign
minister says rail deliveries won't be
enough land corridors
cannot
export full amount of cereals available
for export this is the issue which means
that prices will go up because of the
shortage of delivery Ukraine is now
matching Russia's threat saying cargo
ships in the Black Sea heading to Russia
would be viewed as possibly carrying
military cargo meaning they could be
targeted but its people in poorer
Nations like Lebanon and Ethiopia that
rely on Ukrainian grain who are also in
the crosshairs and desperate for a
resolution
Crystal gemancing Global News London
I had the hunch for a wild animal
believed to be on the loose in Berlin
police in Berlin are on the hunt for a
dangerous animal believed to be an
escaped pet lioness authorities were
first alerted overnight of what appeared
to be a wild boar and a lion chasing
each other on the outskirts of the
German Capital residents in the area are
being asked to stay indoors as police
search with night vision and thermal
imaging equipment
Comic-Con has kicked off in San Diego
when attendance seems high despite the
fact that it's even less star-studded
than usual Hollywood studios are scaling
back their presence at the convention
due to multiple ongoing strikes which
prohibit writers and actors from
promoting Studio contracted work some
fancy it is an opportunity for the event
to return to its comic book Roots more
than 130 000 people usually attend the
Expo every year
astronomers have discovered a first of
its kind star with two faces researchers
from UBC say it's surface completely
changes from one side to the other half
as hydrogen and the other half is helium
the star rotates on its axis every 15
minutes and was spotted 1300 light years
away during a routine scan for dying
Stars astronomers say it may be
undergoing a rare phase of evolution
playing for equal pay next the labor
dispute on the sidelines of the Women's
World Cup
Canada is in that group with the
Canadian women beginning their quest to
win the World Cup tonight with a match
against Nigeria the two teams are
entering the tournament with similar pay
Equity battles and as Mike Armstrong
reports several countries are using the
event to call for a Level Playing Field
there is a message in this ad but one
you don't see at first it's supposed to
be highlights from France at last year's
men's World Cup
but then a bit of trickery is revealed
the players were all actually from the
French women's team it's a call on the
country to support Le Bleu as they're
called because the soccer skills are
there well one of the most skilled teams
the seventh ranked Canadians posed for
their team picture Thursday
and then got back to preparing for their
first match the players are having to
put their bitter pay Equity battle with
Canada Soccer on the shelf for now
they've been fighting for equal pay and
equal support as the men's team the
women have been without a labor deal
since 2021 there was hope the new one
would be signed before this tournament
that didn't happen but they're close
it's done
um yeah we're just not focused on it
anymore it's
yeah about to get done so
now other teams are struggling with the
same issue in fact that includes
Canada's opponents for its first game
Nigeria right now all of our Focus has
been on Canada the distractions have
been a problem for Nigeria's coach and
for the players the team had talked
about boycotting its first match over
its own pay dispute it can be difficult
to focus at times but as a team
we know we came here for and that's to
play football it's been humbling and
life-changing for all of us but we're
not stopping now one of the co-host
teams in the tournament released a video
this week the Australian women are
calling out among other things the
gender disparity in World Cup prize
money the total prize pool for all the
players is 144 million dollars that's
about a quarter of what the men played
for last year every single player in
this tournament deserves the world and
deserves the equal treatment from their
federations
now FIFA has said each player will make
at least forty thousand dollars but the
group that represents professional
players says about a third of the teams
don't have Collective agreements and
that there's no guarantee the money that
players have been promised will get to
them Mike Armstrong Global News
and that's global national for this
Thursday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is this rare spirit bear near
terrorist British Columbia we love
senior Canada so please keep emailing us
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other
good night
[Music]